uh while we're talking about celebrities
and babies this is my the other great
story of the week justin bieber yes
is the subject of a paternity lawsuit a
20 year old woman named mariah yeter
claims that she had sex with justin
backstage
in october of last year at the staples
center in los angeles had sex with him
backstage and that sex resulted in a
baby who's now three months old she
claims justin's the father and she wants
to and her words have justin provide
adequate support for my baby
and that motherfucker's like baby baby
baby [ __ ] no
bieber says he never met the woman right
his lawyers say that they are false
claims and they will vigorously pursue
all available legal remedies to stop
this action against justin i i mean
honestly i don't know there's cat from
adam but everything i've ever heard of
him he don't sound like the [ __ ]
backstage type well no first of all he
has no genitals whatsoever yeah
he's smooth like a like a gi joe doll
between his legs second of all they'd
have to tie a board to his ass to keep
him from falling in he's so little yeah
have you seen the photos of this broad
too by the way of the chick yeah
rough rough really if i was justin
bieber i could have my choice of anyone
in the audience this is not the girl i
would point out and say security go get
her for me maybe he likes to set the bar
low this is my favorite part her
affidavit they've got it printed here
that this came with her paperwork okay
let me read you a little bit as she
describes their encounter backstage at
the staples center hold on turn the
lights down i'm gonna need to jerk off
no he won't just listen the security
guard who worked for bieber apparently
said do you want to meet justin and she
said yes so he brought her backstage and
then this is what happened immediately
it was obvious that we were mutually
attracted to one another i can see it i
can see it and we began to kiss
shortly thereafter justin suggested i go
with him to a private place where we
could be alone i agreed to go with him
and on the walk to a private area he
told me he wanted to make love to me and
that this was going to be his first time
come on man she blew it she blew it she
had me and then she threw in the [ __ ]
lie the private place ended up being a
bathroom backstage
we went inside and immediately his
personality changed drastically he began
touching me and repeatedly said he
wanted to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me oh
yeah i'm back come back
at the time i asked him to please put on
a condom for protection but he insisted
he did not want to
he said that because this was his first
time he wanted to feel everything
maybe he was just like i don't believe
in condoms
believe
yeah
this is where she gets me this is where
i think she's telling the truth okay he
was on top of me with my legs around him
at the time i was on top of some sort of
shelf
she's [ __ ] at the staples center not
a staple store i don't know where she
thinks she is
the sexual intercourse itself was brief
lasting only approximately 30 seconds
i mean you know
how old is he at the time 16 yeah she
was 19 which leads me to my next story
that's statutory rape yeah isn't it it
is
the
los angeles police commander said this
week hey
that's statutory rape
and said there will be an investigation
into this situation and a possible
arrest for this woman who is trying to
bilk justin bieber out of millions of
dollars so she might have to go to jail
for this yes and have her baby in jail
no the baby's born already the baby's
three months old oh okay looks just like
justin i like the notion of i mean just
like i mean they're the same size and
everything looks just like justin wears
a douchey hipster glasses has his ears
pierced
uh sings in a possibly high register it
was just like justin right on uh but
they said they're going to investigate
and here's the thing so if you're her
you're hoping that the dna test comes
out
justin but then you're sort of not
because the minute it does they slap the
cuffs
here's the thing i didn't know if you're
only three within three years of the
minor you're having sex with yeah it's a
misdemeanor
if you're older than three years it's a
felony
explain so if she was 19 he was 16. yes
she falls in that three-year range so
it's only a misdemeanor yeah but still a
year in in prison which they could
probably reduce down to like time served
here's a ticket right because [ __ ] at
the end of the day your punishment is
you [ __ ] justin bieber that's right
you had sex with a little lesbian with a
penis that's what happened to you and
everyone knows that's right
[Music]
you